a new calf joins a herd that's grown
over the past four years
the animals are a mix of local and
foreign breeds and the result of a
government scheme to improve herd
management
and minimize conflict between farmers
and
hurdlers
with spacious housing and a constant
supply of feed and supplements
farm managers say business is thriving
we got at least six jersey pregnant cows
and brongas and hollistein cattle from
the government
they helped us upgrade our facilities
which enabled us to expand and employ
more hands
milk production is up and we even sell
off excess cattle
because of the upgrade he says milk
production has grown by three hundred
percent in three years
and continues to increase the so quarter
state government started the program to
stem violence sweeping many parts of
nigeria
as competition for land and water
intensified between livestock farmers
and those growing crops the state is
expanding the program
just as hundreds of cattle farmers
forced from the southern parts of
nigeria
by the violence are moving north we have
19 grazing reserves that are provided
for these hurdles and
we have started demarcating some of them
so that the farmers will now know their
limit of
encroachment if they have to and where
there is a possibility of trying to
cohabit one another between the famous
and the hardest as we have in some of
these locations
that has been taken care of the cattle
farmers are taught to grow further for
their herds and veterinary skills
the government has made cattle routes
safe they're not obstructed or
encroached upon in areas where the new
scheme is up and running
we also have dams where our animals
drink
the hearts men are also encouraged to
form milk cooperatives
and send their produce to government or
private milk processing facilities
nigeria's cattle population is estimated
at 14 million
three million of them here in sokoto
state but while deadly violence
involving cattle herders and farmers is
reported
across much of nigeria here in sakoto
state there's been no major incident
over the past six years the government
says its plans
to settle pastoralists is bringing calm
and raising output
violence between farmers and herders is
a decades-long problem in nigeria
but has worsened recently and many hope
that initiatives like this
might help bring that to an end ahmed
idris
al-jazeera sokoto nigeria